it smells yeah it does
the copper wire the copper where you got
it i got it okay you got it now don't
let it touch it
when you're coming out that's what i was
trying to say before
okay now make sure that when you pull it
out you don't pull out that matter at
the end of it that was it
[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
as this year comes to a close we're
taking a look at the best films of the
21st century
so far from some huge box office hits to
winners of the most
oscars we're breaking it all down with
the help of film critic
scott mance scott all right how have
films
changed over the past 20 years
well that is a bold and a loaded
question but for if you really want to
take a look
at how movies have changed look at the
marvel cinematic universe look at the
way
the superhero and comic book movies have
become
the biggest and the top grossing movies
of the year
the biggest grossing movie of all time
is avengers endgame which actually beat
avatar
so it holds a new spot but you know the
last 20 years
the superhero the comic book genre has
really held its own
starting with the first x-men movie
which came out 20 years ago
i think that the fact that we've seen
these superhero movies
become the top grossing films and what
marvel has done what kevin feige has
done with marvel studios
the way you have the phase one and the
phase two and the phase three
you have all the superheroes popping in
and out of out of each other's movies
that is really that the game changer
because
other series and other franchises are
trying to do that
star wars is trying to do its own
cinematic universe
so marvel really did change the game and
and and
really that is the uh the success story
of movies in the 21st century
so can you recommend a couple of films
that resonate and speak to what was
popular at the time that they came out
well i definitely want to say one movie
that i think is one of the very best of
the century is get out
like when that movie was over we were
all just like
what was that like it was such a bold
original film
it was an allegory for racial
stereotyping and tolerance but it was
done
in such an original and entertaining way
and a provocative way i mean it was a
horror thriller it was a psychological
thriller there was a
some levity and humor in there daniel
colloya and allison williams were
fantastic
and boy did jordan peel deserve that
oscar when he won for original
screenplay
that movie i think was just the perfect
film
to to capture the steer towards
acknowledging the racial stereotyping
and
intolerance in a way that it was
accessible because people were so
entertained by the movie
they didn't realize until they really
thought about it that they were watching
a movie
with a message that was a fun movie to
take people too that didn't know about
it too
because then they come out and there's
they got so much to talk about it's
great that is a fantastic movie
so the other way uh you can look at the
last 20 years
look at the year 2008 2008 was a
landmark
year for movies specifically for comic
book based
movies in the beginning of may you had
the release of
iron man which is a great film robert
downey jr
was absolutely perfect as
tony stark he was the role he was born
to play
among others because he's a great actor
but it's also the film that launched the
marvel cinematic universe
which as you know with more than 20
movies now over these last uh
12 years has become just an
unprecedented uh movie series in the
history of motion pictures
and that first movie had to be good but
also just a couple months after
iron man opened you had the release of
the dark
knight directed by christopher nolan
that was a game changing film right
there because
i mean yeah it's batman and the joker
but the movie was so grounded in reality
and heath ledger you know he won the
academy award for
supporting actor after he passed away
but the movie was just so
plausible it was a mob movie and it
really raised the bar for how
these superhero movies can be but also
2016 was another landmark year
because you had two completely different
films
that are both amazing for completely
different reasons
and they both did very well at the
academy awards
of course the the one that i love the
most is
lava land i was a big champion and
cheerleader for that film
the movie really spoke to me about my
love for hollywood
my love for los angeles and uh emma
stone who i adore
had great chemistry with ryan gosling it
was a magical film
the music was great the score was great
it was just a real
feel-good crowd pleaser and there was
magic to it
and it won six academy awards including
director
and best actress for emma stone you know
moonlight
you know one best picture also like
supporting actor
for uh mahershala ali you know that was
a groundbreaking film in its
own right for diversity and it was like
brokeback mountain
it was a wonderful beautiful beautiful
film that still
holds up those two movies sort of make
the rounds during the awards season in
2016-2017
comedies were over performing in the
early 2000s way back in the old days
but now the biggest box office films are
horror
what do you think that says and and how
does that inform us
of what genres will have a comeback in
the next decade
you're right to point out that wrote
like comedies and romantic comedies
have started to uh taper off at the box
office
in in in its way we saw all these uh you
know of course the superhero films and
the comic book movies and of course star
wars movies
but horror films people
love to be scared
everyone loves a good scary
movie and over the last 20 years in the
21st century
the best horror movies worked better as
psychological thrillers than they did as
like
friday the 13th or halloween when you
look at like the best horror movies of
the 21st century
obviously get out is like one of the
very very best but you also have
28 days later from 2003 directed by
danny boyle
mulholland drive from 2001 david lynch
is not the typical horror movie that you
think of when you think of a horror film
but it is very scary very creepy very
unnerving
this year one of the very best movies of
2020
the last movie that i saw in a movie
theater was the invisible man
oh yeah it was brilliant
i actually saw that in a theater three
times
i mean that film was one of the very
best remakes in modern times elizabeth
moss was so great
it was a movie with a message in the
metoo and the time's up
years that we've had in these last three
years but the thing is this
why do people love to be scared why do
horror movies
thrive and and why have they stayed
popular
in these last 50 years since like
rosemary's baby and the exorcist and the
reason for that
is because more than any other
experience that you have watching a film
whether it's something that makes you
sad or something that makes you laugh
no sensory experience is more
engrossing than when you are scared
when you are in survival
mode no part of the brain gets a better
workout
than when you are scared you are so
committed when you are watching a scary
movie like invisible man
or like the conjuring or like one of my
favorite movies of 2018
a quiet place fantastic
it was great it was ingenious so these
are the films
that i think the horror movies that will
be the first among the first in addition
to the marvel and the dc movies
to bring people back to the theaters
because people love to be scared
man scott i'm totally with you about the
theater's making a comeback i miss the
popcorn
i miss the popcorn so much all right
scott well thanks for coming on the show
where can people find you
okay well you can follow me on twitter
and on instagram
at moviemance i also have
a youtube channel which i just started
this year finally and my youtube channel
where i'm producing and editing my own
film content including reviews but other
shows as well
my youtube channel is just scott mance
so just check that out and also if you
live in southern california you can
catch me every friday morning on ktla tv
channel 5 the
emmy winning uh morning broadcast with
sam rubin and company
uh they're great and it is so great to
see you thank you so much for having me
i'm so glad we got to do this man happy
holidays you too stay safe
available to watch at home is the last
shift
you got any fast food experience
just eating him you know i just don't
think he's a good figure
and it's your job to train him written
and directed by andrew cohn
the last shift stars richard jenkins as
a man quitting the graveyard shift at
fast food emporium
oscars chicken and fish after 38 years
his unhappy replacement is a talented
young writer who's experiencing writer's
block
and his provocative politics keep
landing him in trouble
these two who share little in common are
brought together through circumstance
and available to watch at home on friday
is shadow in the cloud
when flight officer mod garrett boards a
b-17 flying fortress clutching a radio
bag with top-secret contents
strange happenings begin to occur she
finds there's more to fear than the
tormenting crew and encroaching enemy
bombers
as she's terrorized by something lurking
within the clouds
the film is directed and co-written by
roseanne liang
all right well that's it for today but
leave us a comment and let us know what
is your favorite film of the last 20
years
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]